so vorstellen dass dieses Auto so parkte
dass ich praktisch als die Tür sich
öffnete war das das Bild also ich konnte
wirklich nur in das Auto einsteigen also
hier passt man so gerade rein und dann
wurde die im zugemacht und dann war es
dunkel Peter Kolb ist 23 Jahre als die
Stasi ihn nach einem Fluchtversuch in
einen Transportwagen sperrt
praktisch Luft raus das ist so Moment
der absoluten
Ohnmacht also man hat ja nichts mehr in
der Hand also selbst in dieses Auto ein
Unfall baut man sitzt hier drinnen und
ist verschlossen und das versetzt einen
schon in Angst und
da muss ich
häufig daran denken
schlimm war das vorher was dann nie
enden wollte und wo immer nur die Frage
gestellt wurde wollen sie dir der
ungesetzlich verlassen und ich nicht
genug zu trinken bekam also die schlafen
zu dürfen nicht ruhen zu dürfen immer
nur diese Frage zu beantworten
1981 wird Peter Keup nach Cottbus
gebracht vor ihm liegt die Haft in einem
der größten politischen Gefängnisse der
DDR
ich kann mich doch an die Ankunft hier
in Cottbus erinnern als hier kalt dunkel
und irgendwie auch unwirklich war und
wir diskutiert von Hundegebell und von
von
Schreierei hier in dieses in diesen
Zugang gebracht worden und das alles als
Resultat meines
als er nach Cottbus kommt teilen sich
politische Häftlinge und Kriminelle die
Zellen
anfangs wird Peter Kolb mit 17 anderen
Männern in einen Raum gesperrt
den letzten Glauben an sowas wie wie
Gerechtigkeit oder oder
ja dass ich andere Leute durchaus
staatlicherseits um mich kümmern
angemessen das habe ich ja völlig
verloren
Peter Kolb wächst in Radebeul bei
Dresden auf als er 16 Jahre alt ist
stellt die Familie einen Ausreiseantrag
damit beginnt eine Zeit der Repressalien
unter anderem darf er die höhere Schule
nicht besuchen fast sieben Jahre hält er
das aus dann will er in den Westen
fliehen und wird gefasst
Peter Keup arbeitet heute als Historiker
in seinem ehemaligen Gefängnis ein
besonderer Termin steht an er trifft
einen ehemaligen werter der unerkannt
bleiben will fast zehn Jahre lang hat er
hier gearbeitet bis zur Wende
ich habe damals glaube ich
mit 900 Mark angefangen und dann wo ich
die Anfangszeiten fertig hatte ich war
vielleicht soweit
1.200.300 Marke also ostmarkt damals das
war schon eine ganze Menge Holz ich
hatte ja mehr verdient wie meine Eltern
zusammenfasst ich hatte Respekt vor den
Schließern weiß immer mal auch hieß der
und der der
schlägt sofort zu und der ist ganz okay
[Musik]
wichtige Informationen von zu Hause
erreichen die Insassen oftmals nicht
das habe ich in dem Moment erlebt als
dass ich dann im Monat nach der Geburt
meines Sohnes erfahren habe dass die
Vater geworden bin ja gut alle Briefe
haben die Strafe Gefangenen
immer ist auch die Stadt Sicherheit im
Haus selbst beim Gottesdienst der
katholische Pfarrer war ein richtiger
der
evangelische war eben in oberstleuten
und aus der Staatssicherheit von
Brandenburg kam der wir wussten das ja
aber die Strafe sind halt nicht
dieser Austausch lässt Peter Kolb nicht
unberührt hat sich mit den Worten von
mir verabschiedet hat Spaß gemacht
tja was ist Spaß was ist Spaß wenn man
sich so nur so eine Vergangenheit stellt
was hat das mit Spaß zu tun was kann das
überhaupt mit Spaß zu tun haben aber
vielleicht ist das für ihn so er hat ja
nichts dramatisches erlebt
Berlin
Stasi-Unterlagenbehörde vor rund 20
Jahren hat Peter Kolb angefangen seine
Akten zu studieren nach ihrem Tod auch
die seines Vaters und seines Bruders so
erfährt er dass sein Bruder
inoffizieller Mitarbeiter der Stadt
Sicherheit war
komischerweise ich habe nicht lange
gesucht Ich habe die irgendwo geöffnet
und es war relativ schnell bin ich sagen
dass das erste Blick ich weiß auch nicht
mehr genau aber ich bin eigentlich da
sehr schnell fündig geworden und das war
wie gesagt
ja schon
[Musik]
schwierige Erkenntnis
erst Jahre später findet er heraus dass
ein großer Bruder sogar die eigene
Familie bespitzelte
das ist geschützte Raum den Leuten
vertraut man von den Leuten erwartet man
das nicht und wenn dann sowas
plötzlich so da steht und ich kann ja
nicht mein Bruder anrufen du kannst
sagen immer zu warum denn und ich bringe
maximales Verständnis ich habe mich mit
ihm gebrochen er lebt nicht mehr ne also
ich denke auf ihn ist eine Menge Druck
ausgeübt worden
macht es aber nicht in jedem Fall jetzt
einfacher einwändepunkt bis dahin
leitete er eine Tanzschule die verkaufte
und beginnt mit 54 Jahren Geschichte zu
studieren
habe das dann für mich eben entschieden
da noch mal ja zur Uni zu gehen eben
auch die ganze das ganze Drumherum das
ganze Deutsch deutsche
Durcheinander in Deutschland
wahnsinnigen Blick zu nehmen der ja
meine Familie so
Teil noch kaputt gemacht hat
Peter Kolb besucht seine Schwester in
Dinslaken die Geschwister haben in ihrer
Jugend in der DDR begonnen miteinander
zu tanzen bis zu seiner Flucht nahmen
sie an turnierenteil ein erfolgreiches
Tanzpaar
[Musik]
also das Ereignis wo ich natürlich wenn
ich jetzt an unsere gemeinsame
Tanzgeschichte zurückdenke das war
natürlich der dritte Platz bei der
lehrmeisterschaft 1981 mit dem ja nicht
unbedingt zu rechnen war
in peter-kolbs Tanzschule im Westen
setzen die Geschwister ihre Karriere
fort bis zu dem Moment an dem
herauskommt dass ihr Bruder die Familie
bespitzelte Peter Keup verkauft die
Tanzschule
[Musik]
ich war sauer die Planung war anders die
Planung anders es war eigentlich so die
Planung deswegen gesagt haben klar es
war immer Peters Tanzschule und ich habe
immer da gearbeitet und irgendwie war
die Planung eigentlich so das machen wir
das war alles
anders 7 Jahre lang haben die beiden
nicht mehr miteinander getanzt die DDR
hat das Tanzpaar auseinandergebracht als
es den Start längst nicht mehr gab
[Musik]
Universität Bochum Peter Kolb will in
einem Seminar über das Leben in der DDR
berichten
kurzes auftanken
gerade junge Leute die ja nun wirklich
in diese demokratische Strukturen
hineingeboren wurden nie was anderes
kennengelernt haben naja die sollten
aber trotzdem sollten das genießen aber
eben auch zu schätzen wissen und ich
denke dass können Sie am besten wenn sie
eben Erfahrungsbericht außer Diktatur
hören
auf dem Weg zum Institut für
deutschlandforschung vor wenigen Jahren
war er hier wissenschaftlicher
Mitarbeiter
jetzt kommt er als Zeitzeuge
wenn ich mich vom Ausreiseantrag meine
Eltern distanziere dann kann ich auf der
Schule bleiben man würde mich dann in
eine andere Familie integrieren die für
meine Erziehung zuständig ist ich habe
aber abgelehnt also habe ich für meine
Familie entschieden und damit ging
wirklich seine Ausgrenzung einher
wie die meisten Studierenden ist auch
Jan Lemke geboren als die DDR schon
Geschichte war dass ihr Bruder dann am
Ende bei der bei der Stadt Sicherheit
war und das ist ja das ist eine ganz
andere Art von erfahren und erleben wenn
man da so eine persönliche Geschichte so
präsentiert bekommt weil die
Staatssicherheit und was das technisch
bedeutet und was die theoretisch gemacht
das ist mir durchaus relativ klar weil
ich ja studiere aber so diese diese Nähe
die dann da direkt in der Familie ist
das hat mich doch schon tief beeindruckt
[Musik]
Peter Kolb bekommt immer wieder Besuch
von ehemaligen Mitgefangenen
[Musik]
mit Christoph Osterberg ist er noch
heute befreundet
also hier habe ich dich auf jeden Fall
das erste Mal gesehen hier und ja genau
hier war das
hier genau
reden der der ist ziemlich
niedergeschlagen beide träumten von
einem Leben jenseits der Gefängnis
Mauern Peter Kolb wusste damals nicht
dass in die Bundesrepublik für knapp
97.000 D-Mark frei kaufen wird
Freiheit Turmfalken das waren sie die
begriffserie ich habe so eine Strategie
irgendwie entwickelt nach unten zu
gucken kein anzugucken so mit der Idee
dann werde ich auch nicht gesehen lass
mich auch andere in Ruhe und er kommen
auf mich zu relativ überraschend hat
mich angesprochen und hat eben gesagt
mensch du guckst immer nach unten du
musst nach oben gucken
[Musik]
an seinem letzten Abend in Cottbus
musste er nach der arbeitschicht zur
Strafarbeit in den Kartoffelkeller weil
er die Arbeitsnorm nicht erfüllt hatte
aus Freundschaft ließ sich Christoph
Osterberg damals auch dafür einteilen er
hat dafür gesorgt dass ich hier nicht
kaputt gehe dass ich hier irgendwie
bei mir bleibe durchkommen
ein Freund fürs Leben
gefunden in einer düsteren Zeit
an einem Ort der heute Mahnmal ist für
kommende Generationen